[Music]
the world you live in today was sketched
on paper by european men men who looked
like me
men who at first were just curious and
adventurous but soon whose motives
morphed into an insatiable greed
a confidence that their way was better
than everyone else's
[Music]
this confidence
led to arguably the most influential
series of events in human history
at least the history that affects you
and me
a 500-year project of moving people and
weapons and germs and language and
violence to every corner of our earth
and in the process gathering and taking
home stuff to make them richer metal
rubber tea sugar and human bodies
this isn't a history lesson
you won't hear me talk a lot about dates
and names instead
this is the first of three videos where
i want to show you how this happened how
europe a continent full of poor
miserable farmers took over the entire
world
and in the process
they shaped it they shaped it to their
way of thinking and speaking and doing
things
so this is part one
of how europe stole the world
[Music]
i am out here on a bit of an excursion
near the sea but i want to pause this
video because i need to tell you about
the sponsor of today's video which is
better help a company that is trying to
help you improve your mental health i'm
a giant fan of therapy i've said it
before i will continue to say it i think
therapy is way underutilized in our
society we all have mental health issues
whether we like it or not whether
they're diagnosed or not and better help
is trying to make therapy which is just
working through the things in your mind
more accessible and i'm a giant
supporter of that mission i've been in
therapy for several years it has changed
the way that i think it has changed the
way that i approach my relationships it
has changed me i can say that
unambiguously and very genuinely what
better help is is a platform to make
therapy more accessible to people anyone
around the whole world it's not bound by
geography so instead of looking for a
therapist like in your local town you go
on to better help you sign up you take a
very short quiz and they match you with
somebody in their huge network of like
tens of thousands of therapists once
you're matched you can start
communicating with a therapist in as
little as like 48 hours which if you've
ever looked for a therapist before that
is very very quick that is very easy and
that's what better help's trying to do
is just use technology to make therapy
more accessible i'm a big fan of that
you can choose how you do your therapy
you can do it over the phone you can do
it over video call you could even do it
over like
messaging if you don't want to talk
better help is not like a self-help
program it's not a crisis line it's
legitimate therapy that is done securely
on the internet this is why over three
million people are on the betterhelp
platform taking control of their mental
health so if you want to get in on this
try better help out there is a link in
my description it is betterhelp.com
johnny harris clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gives
you 10 off your first month of better
help so you can try it out betterhelp is
already really affordable there's even
financial aid for those who need it
thank you better help for supporting my
channel for supporting this video and
for making therapy more accessible
okay now back to this incredibly
important story on how europe stole the
world
[Applause]
yes i'm going to be looking at a lot of
maps to understand this issue because
drawing on the map is how they did
things
[Music]
to understand how europe stole the world
we need to rewind to back when the map
looked a little different hold on
[Applause]
back in like 1450
the world map looked like this
[Music]
i mean europe was just a bunch of
smaller kingdoms the borders look so
different than they do today they were
all pretty small potatoes well actually
there actually were no potatoes those
wouldn't arrive to europe for another 50
years but the fact is there wasn't an
abundance of
anything in europe instead europeans
were just farmers barely scraping by
constantly in debt to a few rich
landlords life in europe was scarce and
miserable meanwhile there was a bunch of
other empires around the world that were
thriving there was this big empire over
in the middle east they had silk and
then over here in india you had a big
empire with spices and luxurious cotton
fabrics then of course there was the big
dynasty in china that had by this time
already invented gunpowder porcelain and
really sophisticated ships that they
could use to sail around the world oh
and all of these empires were trading
with one another making all of them even
richer they all had better
everything than europe did and miserable
europeans eventually wanted in on all
the trade
so that's kind of the context here that
sets the stage for europe taking over
the world the first two countries that
wanted in on all this trade and set out
to explore were the countries that today
we know as spain and portugal so they
start looking for a land route to get
them east they start moving east and
nope oh look it's the ottoman empire a
very powerful middle eastern empire
that's run by muslims meanwhile spain
and portugal are hella catholic and
they're not being super nice to muslims
or jews so the ottomans are like no
we're not going to let you pass through
our land to get in on the trade in the
east oh and by the way you can't even
afford our taxes you're miserable
europeans without a lot of money so go
away
they're gonna need another way to go
east
[Music]
portugal's workaround was literally to
go
around the continent of africa
stopping along the coast to trade with
the wealthy african empires along the
way this is a huge moment because it
actually worked
it's near the end of the 1400s and the
portuguese are now going nuts they're
sending ships around this route that
they figured out trading with the east
and suddenly the portuguese are dressing
in luxurious fabrics they're using
cloves and cinnamon and black pepper to
make their food actually taste good wait
a minute you're telling me they didn't
have black pepper before this
geez miserable indeed
so the age of exploration has begun
miserable europe is doing something
about their situation going out to get
in on the thriving trade in the east but
remember this isn't about conquering
land it's about trading
for now
[Music]
okay so now spain sees portugal hitting
the jackpot and they're kind of jelly
they want in on this too they need to
establish their own trade route to asia
but they wanted to do things a little
bit differently
instead of following portugal's leading
going around africa they listened to a
pitch from this italian sailor and this
sailor wants them to fund his new
startup called what if we sailed west to
get to asia instead of east super
promising name now remember at this
point people in europe thought that the
world looked like this the logic was
like oh we can just hop over to asia by
going this other way so spain was like
yes great idea high risk high return do
it columbus
[Music]
well it turns out the world does not
look like this and instead over here
there are a couple of massive continents
that columbus ran into but like many of
us confident white dudes columbus was
like yeah i know exactly where i am
we're like in the indies right now like
over those guys over those are indie
indians yep i can feel it but instead he
was like in cuba but despite the
mansplaining columbus kind of found
exactly what he was looking for and more
great empires with rich culture and food
and precious metal that weren't
available to him back home he was right
on target so he's like alright guys
let's trade but then he's like wait a
minute
these people don't have armies or navies
protecting their stuff so this must be
kind of a different place
different land with different rules
and this is where the biggest light bulb
moment of the century goes off in this
guy's head
change of plans boys says columbus we're
going to claim this land
and everyone was like
wait what
you heard me we are claiming this land
and the boys are like
wait weren't we here to like trade with
great empires portugal's been doing this
for like all these years and getting
rich and he's like no they don't have
armies they're just letting us show up
and like be here without a fight so
obviously that means they don't mind if
we just like claim the land i mean i'm
taking some creative liberty here on
like explaining what columbus was
thinking but like look at the letter
that he wrote
here's the letter that columbus wrote
back to the king and queen reporting on
what he saw
he writes back saying that he discovered
many islands inhabited by numerous
peoples and then i took possession of
them for our most fortunate king making
public proclamation and unfurling his
standard his flag with no one making any
resistance
no one making any resistance
spain and portugal set out to trade they
sent out to like explore and understand
and get in on the global economy but
columbus's realization
was instead of trading they could
actually just claim land for themselves
and this changed everything after all
no one was making any resistance
this moment is the foundation upon which
all european imperialism grows
i'll show you
[Music]
it's the moment that would give us the
first big division in the minds of
europeans the thing we wrote on paper
the old world versus the new world this
is really familiar language to us now
but it was invented in this moment the
new world was now seen as land that
could be claimed it was fair game to go
conquer because they didn't have big
armies or a christian king forget trade
with the east said columbus there's a
bunch of land that we can go take over
in the west
and the race was on
spain and portugal didn't want to fight
with each other over all this land this
conquest that they were about to
undertake so they got together and they
drew some lines
[Music]
no literally they just drew two straight
lines we have africa we have europe and
then we have this line everything left
of this line is spain's everything to
the right is portugal this is literally
one of the original maps where they
actually drew these straight lines and
divided the world into two but let's
look at this on a nicer looking map
please
[Music]
there we go now we can see very clearly
oh look now we understand why they speak
portuguese in brazil
so spain and portugal now have their
spheres of the world that they can go
conquer they didn't ask anyone they
didn't negotiate with the locals they
just drew these straight lines the pope
actually helped them broker the deal
classic but again this is a huge thing
that i want to explain in this series
that these were not just lines they
weren't just like lines on paper they
were actually a shift in the paradigm a
new way of thinking about the world no
one making any resistance it was a story
that europeans could now tell themselves
old world versus new world claimed
versus unclaimed a new way of thinking
think i'm being overly simplistic about
this let me show you something
[Music]
one
two
three
four
these
were a juicy find
[Music]
i found this amazing portuguese nautical
atlas it's a bunch of maps that the
portuguese navy drafted up right after
these two lines divided the world
between spain and portugal and it is an
amazing series of maps but not only
because it's visually stunning
but also because it lets us into the
mind of how the portuguese saw the world
after they divided it with spain
[Music]
this atlas reads like a storybook it's
like the portuguese were so giddy about
giving themselves permission to steal
half the world that they had to write a
children's story about it that's what it
feels like that's not what it is but
just look at this here's the title page
you can see that at the center is the
sphere that was given to portuguese
brazil
africa
what is now the east indies and here on
every corner you see these angels that
are blowing wind into the sails of the
portuguese who are out on their land
grab mission
[Music]
so this is just the title page
the subsequent pages of this atlas are
close-ups on different regions
this is the caribbean over here look
this will become cuba this will become
haiti dominican republic north america
south america all of this unclaimed up
for grabs here our story depicts all
these flags some of them are spanish
flags on the islands on their side of
the line but then you have portuguese
flags on the portuguese side of the line
the status of this land according to the
fantasy of the portuguese changing from
unclaimed to claimed by men on ships
with christian crosses on their sails
showing up and planting flags this was
like playing a board game to them
here's another page this one's a
close-up on brazil
and look we've got people over here
we've got dark-skinned naked people with
primitive tools and no homes
it looks like down here in brazil they
spend their days chopping wood naked and
dancing all while being gazed upon by
fantastical birds and
dragons this was an official naval atlas
drafted for the king and if its message
wasn't clear enough on how these people
should be depicted the atlas has a
little info box up here where they say
that the brazilians are quote savage and
very brutal
this is one of the first atlases ever
made and it wasn't really a navigation
tool
it was much more a declaration of a new
way of seeing the world unclaimed
territory subhuman people all of it up
for grabs by christian boats
so yeah this is how it all started
under this new paradigm both empires
expanded very quickly forcing the
spanish and portuguese languages across
the ocean
mining vast quantities of silver
creating plantations for tobacco and
sugar and in the process massacring the
people who were living in this new world
both with their weapons but also with
their european city germs that the
people being conquered didn't have
immunity to i mean this whole thing
started with curiosity with a thirst to
get in on the trade in asia but soon as
this fantasy of unclaimed land came into
the picture the goal shifted the project
pivoted and soon europe was telling
themselves a new story that they
enlightened christians were entitled to
claim it and while this story starts
with spain and portugal
soon it spread
other european countries poked their
head up from their farm work
and said hey we're white christians also
we know how to sail
we want in on this story of unclaimed
land
and that's the next chapter of the story
one that i will tell you in the next
part of the series
[Music]